you still like me yeah good it's not  unusual to go from feeling like your  spouse's lover to feeling like he's just  someone with whom you negotiate  logistics Demi describes Bruce as being  quote tormented by his ambivalence about  being married this despite a whirlwind  courtship that started in 1987 all of my  other relationships prepared me for this  one Jimmy told et about eloping after  just four months of dating what was the  rush to tie the knot I don't know it  didn't seem like there was no rush we  had sort of talked about it laughing  land just in okay she says after giving  birth to their oldest daughter rumor  Bruce wanted her to put her career on  hold and be a stay-at-home mom but she  was driven to work and entered Hollywood  icon status thanks to 1990s ghost  [Music]  they separated in 1998 but remain close  friends even today here's Bruce earlier  this week supporting to me at her book  launch  [Music]  [Applause]